نعود لرصد الاحوال الميدانيه وكذلك
الانسانيه لكن هذه المره في شمال قطاع غزه
معنا من مدرسه خليفه التابعه لانر و في
بيت لاهيه مراسل الجزيره انس الشريف مرحبا
بك معنا انس ربما هذه المدرسه لها قصه
كبيره ويبدو الحرق ظاهرا وواضحا
لكن نريد ان نطمئن عليك وعلى الناس وعلى
ما جرى في هذه المنطقه مرحبا بك انس
حياك الله ن ان شاء الله بالف خير هذه
المدرسه مدرسه شريفه هنا في بيت لاهئ
اقتحمها الاحتلال التقدم البري في هذه
المناطق قام باقتحامها بشكل كامل واعتقال
عدد من المواطنين النازحين كانوا في داخل
هذه المدرسه وايضا هذه المدرسه كانت تضم
الاف النازحين من جميع المناطق هنا في
شمال قطاع غزه الاحتلال اقتحم هذه المدرسه
خلال العمليه البريه وقام ايضا بحرق
المدرسه بالكامل وايضا حرق جميع المركبات
التي كانت بداخل المدرسه وحرق اثاث
المدرسه بالكامل ودمرها بالكامل وقام
باخراج النازحين من هذه المدرسه وكان عدد
من الشهداء في داخل هذه المدرسه وهناك من
هم من ايضا هناك شهداء قاموا بدفنهم في
داخل هذه المدرسه هذه المدرسه الجيش قام ب
طرد جميع النازحين خلال الفتره السابقه من
هذه المدرسه بعد اتشابه مجزره بحق
المواطنين هنا داخل هذه المدرسه طبعا بعد
انسحاب جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من هذه
المدرسه ومن هذه المناطق النازحين لا ماوى
لهم فعادوا الى هذه المدرسه
لرم ما تبقى من هذه المدرسه وليسوا في
داخلها رغم ما اصابها من حرق ومن من دمار
بسبب عدم توفر اي ماوى لهم هنا في شمال
قطاع غزه انس يعني اريد ان استطعت ان ان
تحرك الكاميرا لنشاهد مزيد من صور المدرسه
وما وما يعني وما جرى فيها وما يجري ويبدو
للمشاهد وانت تستطيع ان تحدثنا عن ذلك ان
الناس عادوا برغم هذا المشهد المؤلم
والحرق والمجزر التي جرت عادوا بفعل طبعا
انعدام الخيارات في في الشمال عادوا يسكن
هذه المدرسه
انس صحيح هنا في شمال القطاع المواط
يعانون من هذ هذا الامر بسبب عدم توفر اي
ماو لهم على مستوى شمال قطع غزه لا يوجد
اي مكان امن ولا اي ملاد امن هنا
المواطنون اثناء خروجهم هذه المدرسه نزحوا
الى الشوارع وفي الطرقات لم يجدوا اي ماوى
لهم فمجرد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من هذه
المنطقه والتراجع بشكل كبير كمال قطع غزه
عادوا الى هذه المدرسه كما نشاهد هنا هذه
المشاهد الان النازحين عادوا بشكل كامل
الى هذه المدرسه رغم الدمار الذي حد بها ه
دمار واس وحر كامل لجميع هنا لجميع الصفوف
ولجميع الاداء ايضا هنا كان في ساحه
المدرسه قيم للنازحين تم حرقها بالكامل
ومركبات كما نشاهد هذه